our lives
are the sum of our choices
we cannot escape the past
Ethan this mission of yours
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing
War
is coming
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represents
it knows your story and How It Ends
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written
shall we write yours too if anything
happens to them there's no place that I
won't go to kill you that is written
[Applause]
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
[Music]
yeah
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
[Music]
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]